[Musique]
dimanche dernier l'émission sept à huit
s'intéresser au jeune fille prostituée
avec son reportage proxénète des sites
et l'enfer de jeune fille mineure
les équipes du programme ont fait la
rencontre de plusieurs jeunes femmes qui
vivent l'enfer que j'ai essayé d'aller
vers la porte et malice sert à rien la
porte elle est fermée et les clés je les
ai j'ai été séquestré
si on imagine souvent que ses fils ont
directement contrainte aussi étonnant
que cela puisse paraître une grande
partie d'entre elles seraient
volontaires c'est ce qu'explique le
commissaire vianney d'yèvre chef de la
brigade de protection des mineurs il ya
peut-être un moyen un petit peu plus
facile pour toi de se faire de l'argent
les étonner encore le commissaire fait
même un lien offre aux jeunes filles
prostituées la télé réalité
pour lui les exemples de ces candidats
serait l'un des ingrédients qui conduit
des mineurs à faire commerce de leur
corps quand cette jeune fille son nom
comme modèle social les les réussites de
la télé réalité
vous avez les ingrédients pour faire de
l'argent facilement une prise de
position pour le moins tranchées qui a
choqué certains internautes
le reportage sur sept à huit ça me
dégoûte mais un point c'est honteux
alors prostitution chez les mineures un
policier dans sept à huit accuse la
téléréalité choqué alors oui oui d'alors
geithner n'ont pas choqué et puis je
connais bien julien dumond café le
reportage franchement chez c'est une
enquête alors le seul souci c'est que le
policier là-dessus disait quelques mots
il développait pas mais franchement où
on sait que ça existe
c'était un reportage et payée qui
dénonce quelque chose qui en ce moment
est en train hélas de monter dans
certains quartiers mais pas que dans les
quartiers qui concerne les jeux d'antan
dans le budget en attention à ces
enquêtes le policer accuse la télé était
en fait d'un site oui mais voilà les
deux donné envie oui aux plus jeunes
oui prostituées et il développe pas
beaucoup mais le fait qu'il dise ça ne
choque pas parce que ce n'est pas faute
du tout ce qui était intéressant fait
c'est qu'ils avaient plusieurs
témoignages d'abord tous très fort alors
il y avait carrément une jeune fille qui
a été séquestrée il ya des filles mais
je me suis malheureusement qui sont
prises par des proxys mai
fille qui le font de leur plein gré
est-ce qu il expliqué c'est qu'en fait
elles ont envie de gagner de l'argent
facile et quand on voit les les voitures
les maisons magnifiques de la télé
réalité
et moi j'ai le regret faut nuancer
d'indiquer quand même c'est de leur
plein gré oui mais parce qu'elles n'ont
rien parce qu'elles n'ont rien parce
qu'elle est c'est pas moi j'ai lu des
choses et en fait ça ya par exemple le
phénomène saillant oui beaucoup
je suis désolé les filles elle le dit
zahia c'était une escorte armée
c'était son métier c'est arrivé si elle
était ou non des halles était attendu il
faudrait l'énergie je dois dire que dire
que les gens se situe par bonnart non
mais j'ai l'impression d'un missile de
seconde parce que toi t'es peut-être un
peu déconnecté et moi qui suis plus
jeune que toi donc je suis plus sur les
réseaux il ya même s'il te plaît en ce
moment des nouvelles influences euse qui
propose à des jeunes filles venues on va
se faire de l'argent facile à dubaï
alors est on rentre 20 30 minutes dans
une chambre
maintenant voilà ce qui se passe que la
télé réalité soit vraiment la boîte amer
de la télé je suis totalement d'accord
mais c'est trop facile
on n'est pas bien moche arrive mais
c'est à la télé j'avais un petit scoop
dans l'émission de cyril où on va on va
recevoir à certains jeux simon castelli
qui habite à l'étroit dans le ciment et
que j'embrasse très fort d'ailleurs non
c'est vrai c'est c'est une eau un peu
dégueulasse que les rétais ya beaucoup
yahya yahya la loire et du rhône à voir
et à manger
maintenant je veux dire mais c'est un
client qui est trop facile on tape
dessus facilement visant la témérité
fabrique maintenant limite des
lancements sont des petites latéralité
ne remplace pas les parents à un moment
donné il ya l'éducation il ya les
parents que la télé réalité donne envie
à des jeunes filles de de dieu d'avoir
du succès par le vide et en aucune en
étant que joly ok on ne peut pas accuser
la télé a hérité de tous les maux de la
terre n'en fût c'est trop facile
oui imagine oui dans le truc c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ce que tu dit ludivine
c'est vrai mais sauf que je vois autour
de moi les jeunes sont même les jeunes
hommes dont sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est on n'existe que quand on a des
objets de luxe et avoirs le sac le plus
cher la fin de la pièce et kevin avec
les noms aujourd'hui que non
c'est donc à l'appui des dames à
regarder la casaque la tnt est
responsable ce que dit ce policier est
totalement vrai tu peux pas le nier
qu'aujourd'hui tout le toubib tous les
jeunes dans l'est dans les cours d'école
dans la rue ils se sont existantes et
par par le lui
lui dit qu'on voit casey le pape y
reconnaît braqueurs mais certains
pouvaient de tel-aviv ont été tués bien
sûr j'étais d'accord oui oui maxime
attention je n'ai pas dit que la télé a
été fabriqué mais bon si tu es c'est
plus mon cas une influence déjà aussi
par un direct déjà aussi aux enfants en
sixième avec leur portable sur internet
et tout ça justement à l'école ils
bloquent les téléphones mais les plus
jeunes mais n'en 6e
ils vont dans les toilettes ils ouvrent
leurs portails et regardent sur internet
tous les trucs pornographiques
donc ça va ça commence déjà là et c'est
inadmissible de 1 non mais vous les
lirez totalement mais vous avez une
vision de la jeunesse qu'est le délirant
non mais arrêtez mine alors tous les
enfants aiment le luxe tous les enfants
dont dans les toilettes au voleur
pendables moi j'ai des enfants qui ont
écouté mois entre 4 5 mois et et 23 mai
mais de grands vous avez quatre ou cinq
ou non sept ou huit ans il a laissé mon
ordinateur et je m'en suis rendu compte
en faisant l'historique et leurs motos
de moteur de recherche était vieille
femme à gros seins
[Rires]
samia que les jeunes effectueront un
accès malheureusement facile
c'est omar en deux responsables français
qui ont regardé une émission attention
ce n'est pas la vérité maintenant mais
maxime tout ce qui se passe c'est faux
c'est tout le temps derrière le départ
ans à l'école cette réalité c'est pas
derrière le dos des réseaux sociaux même
d'influencer pas la télé c'est les
réseaux sociaux les influences et on est
d'accord c'est ce que la télé a été est
responsable la différence c'est qu'on
mélange réseaux sociaux et télé réalité
en fait une différence c'est que rejoint
ce qu'elle est et ce que dit ludivine
elle s'appelle dit ludivine non mais
c'est vrai c'est que en fait la télé
réalité n'est pas répond rl pas
responsable de tout aujourd'hui sur les
réseaux sociaux on voit des choses par
exemple
par exemple on parlait de luxe tout à
l'heure il ya beaucoup de trucs de luxe
qui sont abordables aujourd'hui parce
qu'on vend beaucoup de faux et en fait
c'est tout dans le paraître aujourd'hui
on va sur instagram tout le monde a une
vie de ouf tout le monde vit à dubaï à
une vie exceptionnelle alors que tout le
monde mange des pâtes et dans le froid
une semaine après mais c'est juste du
paraître cela dit la de la différence
c'est que ce que dit la personne dans
les images c'est que en fait je pense
que c'est les réseaux sociaux qui sont
responsables de plein de choses plutôt
que la téléréalité latéralité wii sont
exposées sur les réseaux sociaux mais ça
fait prier pour que je faisais sicap
story nous on était très très très
vigilants sur les candidats parce
qu'effectivement il y avait il y avait
ce qu'on a vécu est classifié les codes
dubaï louis saha et des figues travaille
beaucoup à dubaï ya quelques instants